so the chicago's teachers union has
suggested that they are not going to go
back to work
in fact they are currently engaged in
what most legal interpreters believe is
an illegal strike
backed by the american federation of
teachers backed by
the the biden administration presumably
the chicago teachers union has said
we are we are not going to reopen until
it's perfectly safe
what does that mean they've yet to say
they believe that
they need more diversity hires and i
have no idea why that has to do with
covert they they also are saying
that they want to make sure not just
that kids are wearing masks but that
every kid is is tested and is negative
or every kid is vaccinated like okay
it's just an excuse they don't want to
go back to work
and so they have i think provided us
with the greatest example of why
teachers unions should not exist i have
ever seen and i don't even mean the
strike
i mean that over the past 24 hours the
chicago teachers union
put out a little film of teachers unions
dance
teachers dancing for school closings
i've never seen a better case for
defunding
the chicago teachers than this number
one that these people have jobs
and number two that these people feel
that this is important work what they
are doing right here so
here are six chicago teachers union dan
teachers
dancing for school closings it's
magnificent stuff
and i will i will give you what it says
underneath
safety is essential
keep our students and our teachers
safe
[Music]
our children deserve to be
safe
um i don't think any of those people
should ever work again
i'm not a member of the council culture
but if i if i were if i were
everyone in this video should be
canceled
[Laughter]
yes you clearly are leading a very
difficult life being paid
to do nothing while dancing on a bridge
alone
good stuff solid stuff right there by
the way one thing you definitely cannot
do
is have dance classes outside definitely
can't do that
safety is essential this is and the
chicago teachers union put this out as a
piece of propaganda on their own behalf
as long as we're talking about
government incompetence so the
government has decided to cave to these
jokers
which is just amazing then i love this
too
andrew cuomo the worst of all american
governors okay just this guy is just a
bleep show
he literally i can't believe this guy
like there are no words to describe how
horrible andrew cuomo was the guy won an
emmy they considered him as a
possibility for vp
here is andrew cuomo saying yesterday
that what we need is better government
more power better government he said
incompetent government kills people
does he own a mirror our mirror is
illegal in new york
new york has still still the second
worst deaths per million ratio
in america after new jersey here is
andrew cuomo
saying incompetent government kills
people i i just
th the lack of self-awareness it's
pretty incredible here he is give that
man an emmy
we were ambushed like no other state
nicole
and again it was from federal
incompetence
they thought the virus was in china it
had love china had gone to europe and it
came here for three
months before they ever knew incompetent
government
kills people incompetent government
kills people more people died than
needed to die
in covet that's the truth okay you know
what would be really bad
is if then somebody wrote a triumphal
book about their own leadership
on kovid and then new york got hit by a
second wave of covet that'd be really
bad right that'd be kind of incompetent
leadership andrew cuomo i love nicole
wallace just in there
so true so true facts don't care about
your feelings and it's a fact that the
ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content